hi I'm Tommy
I'm there I perform IBM and my coworker
animist unfortunately he couldn't make
it today because it had a conflict with
his schedule but I believe he's
twittering underneath so we're gonna get
in touch with him and today we are going
to talk about how to deploy and use a
motor framework distributed learning
platform on Cuba Nettie's so I would go
with the agenda for today I covered the
overview for my team Cote which is the
open source arm team then we will go
over how air and clouds complimentary to
each other I will introduce our open
source project fabric fatigue learning
and how do you leverage the platform to
do this repeated reading so our team
today is Stanfill Center for open source
data and IA technologies and our goal is
to aim improving the enterprise AI life
cycle in this using open source projects
and one some of my project done in the
team is fabric for deep learning is a
platform to provide a scalpel resilience
and fault tolerance deep learning
frameworks to train on communities
another project we are working on is the
advanced 360 which is a Python package
open source that help detect and remove
biases in machine learning models
another project we've done is another
Python package called
IP server business toolbox which helped
to create the serial machine learning
using your existing classifier then we
also have something called model as
exchange with package arm or the machine
learning active learning model with
develop and let
application user to able to apply
instantly on their partitions I also
have my enterprise gateway which able to
turn your local triple node kernel and
set those local and remote spark roster
and given a clustered executed and
lastly also a active team that
contribute to spots so you go to us any
spark conference you would see my
coworker walking around there as our
co-op team is we want to create an
end-to-end solution just using open
source technology and as you can see we
have really contributed some of the main
open source project on
the pipeline doing annalen analyzing
data machine and deep learning and
deployment on models so now I'm going to
introduce how AI and throw is
complementary to each other so white AI
in these klaus AI especially on deep
learning workload require extensive of
computing powers so we need a way to do
high performance computing and elaborate
GPUs to accelerate the roads also on
cloud you have the ability to scale your
AI lost with your a I long as your f
growth also on when you quite the arm
elaborate the high-performance computing
some encounter many problems such as how
do you parallel all the models and data
and you have problem encountering when
you try to scale up with internal
communication using MPI or you want to
scale up with multiple GPUs in single
node with the coast and to do that we
need to make it a cloud native for the
AI bowler which means we need like micro
service to manage our lifecycle arm on
the our guru load or and we need to
create containers to make it stable
environments and then we need to create
automations on to develop teams to able
to automate or this process that we
don't have to do the step over again and
to do this we introduced our project
fabric for deep learning that was make
this process simpler fabric for deep
learning provides a very scalable
resilience and first horns are using a
cannon from Cuban Eddie's and apply
those with our deep learning frameworks
and to enable this is built on a micro
service architecture so it will go out
easily easier to scale and easy to
elaborate any features or tests coming
you into given Eddie's the concept here
is you have a platform in your big
cluster and you have many users within
that cluster that could assess and as
allocate data's adequate resource but
everything needed so we have a very
elastic computing environments and also
each of the container is each of the
vocal note in your machine learning is
wrapped in two containers you're aware
stable environments so it's easier for
you to scale and you don't have to worry
about any like internal or hardwood
infrastructure we've done a research
paper about this tree of deep learning
platforms and we have discussed a lot of
challenge we face doing development is
platform for examples how we distribute
out different parameters and gradients
using a baby models of distributed
methods on data distributed effort and
you could look into the research paper
for more details and how how the how we
could retain the accuracy and
performance with multiple GPUs also on
fabric for deep learning is also the
core for our watson studio which is the
service we provide to do data science
tack on the IBM cloud and what's in
studio as you can see we provide many
services not just on machine learning it
also on data processing and the data
model deployments and fado is live under
the data learning runtime stack I mean I
did planning one time stack and deep
learning as a service is the core using
a petal as a core to execute any deep
learning models on Watson studio and
what's nice to the extent that to
provide a nice visualization you eyes so
you could get your model status and your
model matrix has a very nice UI display
and also
Boston studio provide a very nice new
and I will moderate so for deep learning
beginners they could go ahead and just
use a drag-and-drop interface and try
out how to peel a deep building models
and we have test these platform on
intensively with boa I wallow on IBM
cloud
in any service and one of our deployment
have reached like 3,000 parts or foreign
notes on out cloud platforms so now I'm
going to introduce the architecture of
the fiddles
as you can see fiddle has a very complex
micro-service design but well factor it
out as you can see we have some micro
service that's more focus on the
disability such as the web UI and rest
api and this like other micro servers
that handle all the lifecycle of the
machine learning loss such as the
lifecycle manager and trainer service
and we also micro service to handle all
the data crafting and metrics collecting
from the models and when you execute the
job the job will allocate the resource
for Cuban ad cluster as a part and then
you amount on an object storage as a
shear storage to asset your data set and
store any models have trained over there
and when you provision it since it's
from Cuban Eddy so it will just put the
container based on the framework you
have chosen or you could bring your own
container in this case to do your
distributed running and we update some
with this without community partner we
community we partner with southern Corp
which is a machine learning deployment
platforms aren't abilities so we
corroborate them and elaborate the model
restore in object storage and use them
to serve it directly on the same cluster
or on the different custard for the
production or what load and then we also
cover it with h2o AI which is a machine
learning free book we also enable multi
node crusting control computing with h2o
AI so you can elaborate the same
features using the wrapper for deep
learning we also cooperate with our hard
work from uber which it provides a very
nice MPI ring of reduce algorithms in
addition to they also have a good
elaboration between
MPI and Nicole a communicative act so
you could do a very nice combination of
[Music]
scaring out with mother bundle and scare
up with multiple of gpus Pernod and
finally we integrate with our episode of
a sense to Buster how that they attack
any like robustness in your models like
my models the test set my not able to
cover all the edge cases is your models
we want to calculate the true accuracy
from the model in the real world use
case so now I'm going to explain why
demos well the demo structure will first
we have some data going to the training
and to do the training process and once
the training trained at a classifier
models and data sets you can invert and
trigger the adversarial versus to pass
to create generated you see classified
as the discriminator from then if we
would use teeth are generated to add any
noisy on the original test set to verify
is the classifier robust enough for this
use case or not and at the end we also
put the Prados models using seldom when
the model that are stored in the same
other storage and as future plans will
also try to arm elaborate without
fairness chest so we could add more
metrics on our models to make sure our
models is ready for the production usage
and I'm going to explain a little bit on
what little we need for the training job
so it will need a some model definition
and how your graph is generated then it
would need a manifest positive a high
one a secure job workout which shows you
my need and where your data is stored
and then lastly you will need to put
your data in an object stores so we
could easy to manage and to version
control reducing the object storage
bucket
and a little bit background on the
manifest file we define is we define
what kind of resource is needed within
that training just in for example you
might need a number of GPUs and CPUs per
your container and how we contain that
you might live with our Ginny jobs and
then where your data is located and
credential for how to access to your
data and what come fling what you might
want to use and the entry point command
I want to execute your machine learning
deep learning models and last we you
also have an option to store your
evaluation matrix definitions as a test
board and we'll extract those X matures
on our graphic UI
so now let's go begin without demos
so first we want to connect one of the
fiddle platform instance on plow so you
can see that this sort of training to
help them before and to submit a new
trail is very simple you just choose a
zip file that contains all the model
definition files such as how you want to
execute the models and the manifest file
that defines what kind of resource you
want to use for your training model set
and then we execute on a cloud it would
create a n number of containers for your
jobs and I will show you the status
underneath as from the REST API oh oh
sorry
is it better thing is it um so what's in
this stage because OC was the status of
your own training jobs and wood-frame
what do you use and what's the command
you would use to execute each training
jobs scene for this training job we are
using the community image so we need to
install the terrorists libraries and as
a cute dr deep learning models then we
also see once the training job running
we will also see the last and evaluation
matrix over here so let's go to a job as
complete so from here you will see the
lock of the palace
as well as the aversion matrix over here
and an extra feature we added this
pipeline is we added a pipeline where
once you train your models you able to
do robustness check which it will
provide you an environment to check is
your models cover enough edge cases and
will also able to deploy on the same
given area cluster so once you click the
robustness check just need to define how
many GPUs and CPU you need I think and
then with you store your original models
so we could take that model and ask some
robustness check to it so once you
submit it it would take some time
because they were execute as a server
list actions and at the end we would
create a new trainee job ID which I
think we will refresh in a second
so at the same at the mean Tiger also
deployed models using this similar could
I show you return you the deployment URL
I need to refresh it
so the robot says check a job you have
similar to the original debugging job it
will show you what the robustness job is
doing basically we'll take the original
models and the pipe the adversarial rule
is to box method we in this case we're
using the of fast a gradient attack and
once the professor's checked job is done
I can show you one of the yourself we
have over here you show you a list of
metrics it will show you first your
original model accuracy on the baseline
test data and then the accuracy on the
ever serial sample which you can see is
decrease it more than sixty percent
which means it has that didn't cover
enough edge cases for your models and
you also could see the percentage of
reduction in competency which in this
case on average it reduce for the free /
self-confidence in rate and the average
of perturbation rate is also very low
which I mean it makes sense because we
training on a fashion endless data set
which everything have a same black one
that's why the test that isn't covering
of edge cases in this case so from here
I want to introduce a little bit on dai
fairness 360 where we want to elaborate
that in our fatal project in the future
they have been a 360 is a Python tool
kit which allows you to apply some
fairness check and here is the list of
available metrics you could do
so each metrics have its own fairness
definitions because we cannot define
fairness just using one definition so
the server of them depends on the used
case of the models and we also provide
ten different algorithms how to you with
reprise that we balance your arm machine
on machine learning models using may be
waiting on your data's
itself or enhancing your optimizer to
include like fairness constraints or you
could enhance your they test set to test
more edge cases to cover more fitness
metrics and you want you can learn more
about the AI fairness of research C to
bust by going to AF 360 dot my
bluemix.net and I will show you a quick
demo how this pattern package group
works so you can pick a data set from
here in this case which you use the
German credit scoring for our examples
then it will run dig up the fitness
checked with five different fairness
message with defined as we can see the
sex attribute doesn't have any bias in
this case however for the H attribute we
can see this for different measures of
that has bias over here and you can see
more details by clicking on the
definition of each measures and from
there you could take different my bias
my Croatian algorithm this three type of
process went into my past my Croatian
one is doing the pre-processing we are
data the second phase is doing the
classifier if you add constraint to your
optimizer and the third one is of you
add extra tests on your test case to
cover more edge case uses
um so for example we'll show you how to
use they were waiting which will we wait
the data set to be more balanced
so as you can see up to the we're
waiting with the original attribute for
the sex attribute it doesn't change much
however with the Asia attribute it will
reduce the bias up by a lot for each of
the metrics pre-measure however is still
not enough because by just we waiting we
cannot come get rid of all the biases
that happen during this model because we
also need to add constraint
during the training time and need to add
more fairness check during the
post-processing which are on your test
sets and that is the end of the demos
and if you have it to anyone have any
questions yeah go ahead
we saw spot oh this one
Oh JSON file
oh here it's one resource file for every
training job just for every kind for the
container you trained for their jobs
yeah the only one yeah yes so everything
I showed the day is freeze or open
source I would say you would only need a
machine to run them but if you don't
have a machine you could go to the
Watson studio which it provides
everything at I think we will provide a
lot of the feature SPT and you want to
expand that with a real world load then
you may have to pay it's free they have
a free chair you could try out with I
think you could try out with two of to
four GPUs bring a feature and you get
fifty training hour per month for free
you could use any crowd because our
platform is a white sauce yeah anyone
else have a question yes
so we do have a way to so we do have a
way to pass and not possible more on
housing whatever job you're running so I
think from my cursory on my UI there's a
DD button so even in the planning job in
during the processing stage you could
take this
DD button and the lifecycle manager
would try to hold your current training
Java and allocate those resources
it's unacceptable I don't predict but
yes it is possible but right now we on
open source side we only allow user to
tool put in their own code base but we
are planning to integrate that in the
product to automatically for you yeah
anyone asks of question yes all right so
let's go back to the definitions so so
when you define the resource you have to
define how many GPUs and see if you
really want allocate for each container
and underneath you have the learner
session which defines how many container
you want to run for that training jobs
and that determined how many resources
you will allocate from the cluster this
is their answer their questions
no balancing of resources so first I
would have to be quite right to say we
use how are you split up that resources
to get the most performance ow
um so the the main wish was um I think
the main resource management is done
from Cuba ladies of community have a
wait you just want to spread hub or CPU
core it could do it from the Cuban Eddy
level so yeah so criminais we had
everything from that level down yeah yes
so so for this returning I think the
best distinction is when you have played
a great long-running models and you're
sometimes that bought your model might
have a great big dataset won't able to
fit into a single GPU memories then you
might want to do like data parallelism
which is string the batch size into a
small mini batch and able to fit into
each small GPU you might what everyone
anyone have and have questions yes
control how like deep learning job is
like distributed so are you saying that
you know the user in this case doesn't
really need to work worried about like
how to distribute because like
communities like we'll figure that out
for you automatically
um sorry can you repeat the question so
in some there's some like frameworks
that allow you to kind of like control
controlling how the training is how the
computation is distributed but here it
seems like you just you just like
specify the number of containers that
you want and yeah so so from from from
our example we distributed were low so
we now model definition we actually
define like how do you wanna communicate
between the other worker no rate so we
have a moto gp within the Macondo we
might want to use the the co-packer and
communications so because you wanted to
the internal communication from there
and you want to have like multiple
containers that have a single gps you
want but you might want to use the air
MPI which have a very good internal
communication back in so it varies bit
between this case but right now at this
stage we are turning that our model
definitions that you define
yes yeah it says a Python script for my
samples but you could have a module of
definition for your training deep
learning model because sometimes even
motive could be very big so you might
want to create a whole module for that
yeah anyone else have questions
okay good
[Applause]